[Musica]
nell'immensità del cosmo un astro il
sole naviga cercando il senso della sua
potenza della sua energia incontra
tantissimi pianeti lancio ai suoi raggi
e questi raggi però purtroppo i pianeti
sono aridi quindi i raggi bruciano
questa terra e il sole deluso rilascia e
riparte per un altro orbita cercare
altri altri pianeti
e così per milioni milioni di anni poi
finalmente nel buio e nell'oscuro del
cosmo vive un bellissimo pianeta azzurro
bellissimo si emoziona chi si avvicina e
lancia immediatamente i suoi raggi e lei
l'acqua lo accoglie la forza del sole è
il grembo del mare e scoppiare vita
madre mare e questa vita come lascia
nasce con un piccolissimo piccolissimo
essere che si divide si moltiplica e
invade tutto il pianeta e si trasforma
in uccelli in pesci e mammiferi insetti
e tutti questi esseri che vivono nel
pianeta devono cercare un loro modo di
sopravvivere di moltiplicarsi e creano
dei sistemi molto complicati molto
complessi ma che fanno sì che a un certo
punto dopo un tempo infinito un tempo
infinito creano le condizioni del
pianeta mare nel pianeta dei temi di
vini di remare ma nel pianeta terra
nasce la possibilità all'uomo di vivere
in questo pianeta e quindi madre mare
nel suo grembo nasce
nasce la vita io sono figlia di una
città bellissima che si chiama napoli è
circondata dal mare
l'abbraccio del mare noi napoletani ogni
giorno lo guardiamo e diciamo come bello
la mattina all alba al tramonto in ogni
minuto fa parte del nostro modo di
essere
ebbene sono figlia di armatori ma
soprattutto sono subacquea da
piccolissima sono stata attirata da
questo mondo blu e da sola ho imparato
ad immergermi ad andare sott'acqua a
imparare a compensare naturalmente
quindi senza ostacoli per scendere nelle
profondità marine
ebbene all'epoca immaginavo di un'altra
vita di essere stata un animale del mare
e poi ogni volta che che mimì
mi auguravo che un delfino poteva avere
vicino a me accompagnarmi nelle mie
avventure ben tutto questo quando era
piccola ma appena sono cresciuta
sono andata in cerca dovunque nel mondo
a fare immersioni con i grandi animali
del mare quindi con le balene ei delfini
con gli squali e coleman te forse il
bellissima immersioni collimanti sono
stati quelli più emozionanti e più belle
ebbene a un certo punto ho visto che
madre mare era sotto attacco in tutti i
paesi della terra in tutti i paesi
dall'angolo anche più remoto
c'era chi pesca la che distruggeva e
allora non ho avuto il coraggio di
girare via la testa e far finta che non
vedevo e non volevo perdere quell'eden
meraviglioso che avevo conosciuto dovevo
assolutamente fare qualcosa e con un
grande mal di stomaco da paura perché
non sapevo proprio come iniziare
accompagnata dalla mia amica del cuore
carmen abbiamo fondato un'associazione
che si chiama marevivo e da quel giorno
che ormai risale a più di 35 anni fa io
dirigo questa associazione e sono il
presidente di una squadra di una squadra
di gente generosa grande appassionata
del mare con grande voglia di fare
dedicano il loro tempo libero ad andare
a pulire i fondali affari manifestazioni
a coinvolgere la gente dei bambini nelle
scuole facciamo di tutto e di più ebbene
tutto questo ci ha portato a essere
presenti un po dappertutto ma ha
chiaramente tutto questo non basta ma
per chi facciamo questa cosa ma perché
così importante madre mare
abbiamo detto che la vita i natali va
bene ma poi ma poi allora pensate che il
mare e il 71 per cento della superficie
del pianeta terra
lo vediamo tutto mare e pensate che la
stessa relazione il nostro corpo umano
ce l'ha anche noi siamo fatti del 71 per
cento della parte liquida e 29 della
parte solida e ci pensate che nel nostro
corpo è presente il mare con le lacrime
e piangiamo sentiamo il sale e nel
sudore n e nel sangue
ecco allora il mare è dentro di noi e
dentro di noi ma voi pensate che questo
mare che al 71 per cento che cosa equipe
perché è importante è importante perché
perché produce più del 50 per cento di
ossigeno che noi respiriamo un respiro
su due che noi facciamo tutti facciamo
ci viene dal mare anche delle persone
che vivono in montagna non è soltanto
quelli vicino al mare ma tutti e poi
assorbe un terzo dell'anidride carbonica
che responsabile dei cambiamenti
climatici e poi è il grande grande
motore della del clima del clima pensate
l'immensità degli oceani le nuvole
nascono tutte dal mare ebbene tutto
questo ruolo straordinario che esercita
madre mare lo può fare solo a una
condizione in buona salute che tutti i
suoi esseri che la abitano quindi non è
un è un essere vivo e fatto di animali
di viaggiata e vegetali che vivono in
combinazione tra di loro e se questi
manca un anello di questa catena manca
questo equilibrio
capite che madre mare non può più
esercitare questo ruolo
e chi è che ne va più penalizzato noi
uomini che viviamo sul pianeta ma io vi
vorrei raccontare quali sono gli impatti
più forti quelli che madre marie deve
subire in maniera proprio veramente
molto molto difficile anche da
scardinare
e si parla molto della plastica nel mare
non si parla della plastica la plastica
negli oceani l'aplasia è entrata nella
catena alimentare eccetera ma la prassi
che sono al terzo posto dei propri
sapete chiare al primo posto lo sapete
lo faccio vedere sono i cambiamenti
climatici
i cambiamenti climatici noi vediamo gli
lasciai che si sposi si squagliano e
distruggono vediamo la desertificazione
dei nostri territori perché il mare
brucia troppo ecco guardate qui che
immagini
ma che cosa succede sotto il mare
guardiamo un attimo il fatto che l'acqua
si sia riscaldata e si sia cd ficcata
dei grandi oceani pensa di questa
immensità enormi di a questi sono
acidificate ma perché perché noi abbiamo
bruciato troppa co2 e lei madre mare la
dovuto per forza e assorbire ebbene qui
noi vediamo delle immagini che sono
terribili perché solo di poco tempo fa
che ci arriva la notizia che la grande
barriera corallina dove vivono i coralli
che sono degli animali meravigliosi sono
i grandi costruttori
ebbene per effetto dei cambiamenti
climatici da chi erano pieni di vita
piena di colori si sono trasformati in
questo ecco allora che cosa che cosa
dobbiamo fare
che cosa dobbiamo fare
ebbene le ricette non sono facili e non
sono e non sono facili da digerire però
bisogna bisogna partire
e allora bisogna dire basta basta a
bruciare non dobbiamo più bruciare noi
continuiamo a bruciare da da sempre e
materiali fossili quindi carbone gas e
petrolio
noi dobbiamo passare alla terza
rivoluzione industriale bisogna prendere
il nostra nostra energia che ci serve
per vivere da dall'energia rinnovati ve
dall'energia che ci vengono dal sole dal
mare e dal vento dai dei fiumi dai
vulcani
guardate che noi abbiamo le tecnologie
per prendere queste energie
siamo tutti pronti in tutto il monte lo
possiamo fare questo e questa è la prima
cosa che noi dobbiamo fare cambiare
il nostro modo il paradigma basta di
bruciare i fossili andiamo nelle energie
rinnovabili e pulite e quindi questo è
il primo punto se non arriviamo a questo
è difficilissimo passare agli altri
il secondo tema che anche molto grave e
quello è quello della overfishing noi
stiamo pescando troppo abbiamo pescato
troppo continuiamo a pescare troppo
guardate queste immagini di pesci
stretti dentro le reti ma così a
miliardate dovunque dovunque ebbene voi
pensate che che prima l'uomo viveva no
con i prodotti della pesca come vive
adesso però prima si prelevavano
soltanto gli interessi di un capitale il
capitale di rimanere integro
l'uomo prendeva gli interessi e viveva
adesso noi siamo diventati tanti con
tantissime esigenze quindi tutti
dobbiamo mangiare pesce in qualsiasi
momento eccetera
e poi le tecnologie questi nuovi motori
fortissimi potenti e gli attrezzi da
pesca indistruttibili e poi una cosa
terribile sono tutte le leghe
ecoscandagli che ormai sono talmente
sofisticati che anche se passa un cc
niello sotto la barca viene preso non
c'è più scampo per gli animali del mare
per i figli di madre mare e quindi è un
altro tema molto forte che noi dobbiamo
affrontare in maniera proprio convinta
basta di mangiare animali selvaggi siamo
pronti a mangiare un orso un lupo un
cerbiatto forse no però mangiamo
tranquillamente pesce spada tonno perché
i pesci sembrano non sembrano animali
pensate io in questi anni sono diventata
vegetariana non lo ero napoletana potete
immaginare per me la la cucina del pesce
era parte della mia cultura e bene
andando avanti ho capito che non era più
sostenibile e quando io dico ma sono io
sono vegetariana mi rispondono e ben e
pesce lo mangi ma come il ps domando
e proprio uno degli animali fondamentali
perché l'equilibrio di madre marie sia
completo
e poi arriviamo al terzo impatto che
quello di quali siamo molto più pronti
ebbene impatti questo qua delle
plastiche plastiche inquinamento da
idrocarburi nelle nostre città non hanno
il depuratori
insomma c'è di tutto di più e allora che
cosa dobbiamo fare tutti quanti noi
dobbiamo cercare di avere una vita più
consapevole più con sapere basta l'usa e
getta
basta mangiare cose che non sono
proibite e vestirsi con vestiti che non
siano adatti quindi tutti quei comuni
dove deve fare la propria parte e bene
però ci sono delle buone notizie ci sono
tre potenti se che sono importantissime
allora le notizie che ci sono e è forse
la più importante
intanto la consapevolezza anche della
generazione di giovani che sono entrati
in questo mondo e hanno capito che
bisogna fare qualche cosa ma poi
sappiamo l'europa l'europa ha stanziato
fondi cospicui per andare verso la
direzione del cambiamento
e poi ci abbiamo ancora una cosa molto
bella perché le nazioni unite hanno
dichiarato per dieci anni da quest'anno
in poi li hanno degli oceani quindi vuol
dire andare a studiare a mettere in
campo forze energie per salvare il
nostro nostra madre mare e allora con
questo amici cari che mi avete ascoltato
chiudo dicendo che ognuno di noi può
fare qualche cosa noi possiamo pensare
dobbiamo pensare globalmente dobbiamo
capelli a tutto quello che sta
succedendo ma poi agire localmente
ognuno di noi nel nostro piccolo tanti
piccoli gesti per miliardi di persone
fanno veramente cambiare il trend di
questo nostro meraviglioso mondo che si
sta perdendo
io vorrei dirvi che una bella frase che
erri de luca dice sempre che per me la
sento molto mi sa che il madre ma che
l'immensità del mare e sorella maggiore
del tè grembo materno
ecco noi donne sentiamo molto vicino
questa questo sentimento questo
sentimento noi abbiamo il nostro bimbo
del nostro grembo e quindi abbiamo un
sentimento di di avere cura per la
generazioni future cura ecco questa cura
è importante fare per madre mare il
countdown in questo momento ci segna
continuamente minuto per minuto
stiamo andando verso un punto di non
ritorno
ebbene non perdiamo questo momento che
ancora possiamo fare qualcosa
un momento che quello che facciamo in
questo momento vuol dire per il futuro
nostro e dei nostri figli
quindi vi ringrazio buon lavoro e
soprattutto unitevi a noi ora è il tempo
di agire
domani è troppo tardi grazie
[Applauso]